-Harry, it's great to see you.
And man, it's an honor to have
you here.
-It's so cool to be here.
It's the first time on "The
Tonight Show" in my whole life.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I find that hard to believe.
-Yeah, right?
And oh, by the way, real quick.
"Summer of Soul." Stop.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just so great.
-Well done, Questlove. Yeah.
Harry, we met, I would say,
20 years ago.
I don't know
if you remember this.
You did an A&E biography
on "SNL."
-It was amazing.
We went behind the scenes.
We shadowed the show for a week.
Then we came back
and shot the thing.
And that's when I first met you.
-Yeah.
-And I have this very
crystal-clear memory.
Tuesday night, they stay up
all night and write.
-Yeah.
-And you and I are walking down
49th Street at like 4:30
in the morning.
And I turned to you, and I said,
"Where do you think this
all leads?
Where do you think this
all leads?"
And back then, would you have
had any idea
that you would be sitting
right here right now?
-No.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No. No, never, never.
-Right?
-Wow, no.
-Yeah.
-Not never. Not at all.
I didn't know this was even
a job that someone could have.
[ Laughter ]
But I was just so psyched.
I'm the biggest fan of yours.
I said it backstage, but I'll
say it in front of stage.
Every time I see you, whether
it's a humorous piece you do,
whether it's an emotional piece,
I love you and I have to --
I can't tune out.
You're like when "The Godfather"
comes on TV or "Love Actually,"
I have to watch the whole movie.
-You can't change the channel.
-No, you can't.
I go, "Harry Smith, he's
the greatest," I mean --
-Oh, you're
nice. You're too nice.
-No, you're a pro.
The recent thing you just did
with Al Pacino was awesome.
I thought that was great.
-So the Tribeca Film Festival
screened "Heat"
from 1995, great classic.
Michael Mann film.
And so they had Al Pacino
and Robert De Niro
and we got them backstage
for like 20 minutes.
-Yeah.
-And --
You have --
Do you have any experience
with interviewing
Robert De Niro?
-Robert De Niro, yes, he was
my first interview, by the way.
He was my first guest
on "Late Night."
-And how much did he say?
-He said two words.
He said, "yep" and "nope."
He's like, "Yep."
-We got a couple of paragraphs
from him.
-I mean, you did?
-'Cause I've interviewed him
a bunch of times, and
honestly -- well, he was on
the "Today" show a couple of
weeks ago
talking about
the Tribeca Film Festival.
And here's Hoda and here's
Savannah and they're saying,
"Bob, Bob, Bob."
"Ask Jane. Ask Jane. Ask Jane."
Who runs it with him.
And it's just like --
And so I do all this homework.
I do all this stuff.
And I just say, "Please, please,
talk to me."
And I got lucky.
-Yeah, but you've been doing
this for 50 years?
Is that true? Almost 50 years?
-So, I graduated college
in 1973.
I went to Central College
in Iowa to play football.
But I messed around with
a college radio station,
and I got a job doing
color commentary
on girls high school
basketball games
at the local radio station,
daytime station.
And the local veterinarian
and I would take his pickup
out to see these girl high
school basketball games.
And since it was only on during
the daytime,
we're there at 6:00 at night.
It's not live.
So we had a reel-to-reel
tape recorder,
and we would record the games.
The commercials I wrote for
D&D Pump and Pipe, right?
This is not a joke.
[ Laughter ]
And they would replay them.
Even though everyone knew
the results of the game,
they would replay them
the next afternoon.
-Wow. What, on like A.M. radio
or something?
-A.M. radio, whatever.
KNIA in Pella, Iowa.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
With studios in Knoxville.
-You're an award-winning
journalist.
You've interviewed everybody,
celebrities, royalty,
presidents.
I mean, have you --
have you met the Queen?
Have you met the Queen?
-Yeah. Okay. So...
[ Audience ohs ]
She was on some tour. It's got
to be in the '90s, right?
And there's some big event at
the British ambassador's house
in Washington, D.C.,
and you get the invitation
and just go,
"This has to be a mistake."
I get there and it really is
the royalty of Washington, D.C.
And you get instructions.
Do not address the Queen.
Don't ask her a question.
Don't say boo to her.
So, I'm close to the front of
the line, and I just do
the curtsy or the bow or
whatever you're supposed to do.
-Yeah. Curtsy.
-And I'm like, "I'm not happy
with this.
It didn't work for me."
-Wow.
-So I doubled back --
I double-dipped on the Queen.
[ Laughter ]
I go back to the back of
the line, right,
and I put my hand out,
and I said --
My co-host in the morning then,
Paula Zahn -- I said,
"She knows your cousin or your
something or your something."
And prattle, prattle, prattle.
And she says, "Oh, really?"
We had a little conversation,
which no one else had.
-You did it?
-And then -- And then all
the VIPs of Washington, D.C.,
descended on me and said,
"What were you talking to
the Queen about?"
-Yeah! That's right!
You're like, "Yeah, I'll show
you how to double-dip."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
-Crushing it.
Crushing it with the Queen.
-What are your favorite
interviews?
-Real people. Real people.
Because honestly, I've
interviewed all the presidents.
I've interviewed everybody,
right?
And most of my job, we just go
out into America and I know
if we're paying attention to the
news every day, which we should,
it feels like we're at each
other's necks constantly.
-Yeah.
-It doesn't feel like that out
there, right?
There are people out there
who are building community,
helping their neighbors,
they're loving their neighbors.
That's what it feels like a lot
out there where I like to be.
I've done stories --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Right?
I've done stories
in all 50 states.
I've done from every continent,
including Antarctica,
and my pleasure zone is
out on the road,
out talking to folks.
-Harry Smith, you're a legend.
I love that you're on the show.
Please come back any time.
-This is what happens --
You know the segment
"Thank You Notes"?
I got a thank-you note.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're the best. Harry Smith.
You can see his reports
on the "Today" show,
"NBC Nightly News with Lester
Holt" and "NBC News Now."
Conan Gray performs next.
Stick around.
Harry Smith
on "The Tonight Show."